add more value if you want to be able to
charge what you're worth if you want to
be able to build a successful company
you need to add a ton of value the
amount of money that you make will be
directly related to how much value
you're providing for your customers how
much you're helping them out it's a
pretty simple equation executing it is
difficult but the concept is simple to
understand if you want to make more
money add more value and stop competing
on price when you compete on price alone
it's a loser's game you're not going to
bring on ideal clients you're constantly
struggling to get by you're not gonna be
able to hire great people for your team
you have to stop competing on price stop
start adding more value and you can love
your business more you're gonna have
more fun you're gonna attract much
better clients you want to work with
people who understand the value provide
and not just cater to the guys who have
no budget who are barely paying you a
tiny profit for what you're doing I got
a great question from a YouTube viewer
Corona who has a new scarf so she's got
a scarf product line wants to know how
do I not compete on price how can I
stand out in the scarf market and one of
the ideas that Corona had was to have a
social cause and give a dollar for each
scarf to support hepatitis B
vaccinations of poor children this is a
great concept to start with okay if you
are doing anything social or anything
green you can usually charge a little
bit of a premium typically consumers
will pay maybe 20 to 30 percent more if
they know that there is a green
component or social component to it
okay so add that in use it in your
market and if it's something that you
believe in put that in there okay you
could charge a little bit more but
you're still in a super competitive
market you look at scarves
okay scarves are highly commoditized you
can get scars for you know a couple
cents all the way up to hundreds of
dollars what's the difference between
the the cheap knockoff really fake you
know crappy quality scars
the super high-end ones and where do you
want to play I don't know anything about
your scarf you have to stand out somehow
with your scarf with the design with the
colors with the feel with the material
something you have to have something
different if you are just a normal scarf
like every other scarf on the market
you're not gonna make it you're not
gonna have a lot of success the the
social component is great you might get
a little bit of attention for it but
it's not gonna make the difference you
have to have a truly remarkable product
on top of having a cause that you
believe in for your company so what is
it with your scarf right and this should
be and everything that you talk about
when you tell me about your scarf I
should be able to quickly understand
what makes you different right I could
be telling people about it on this
youtube video here's the scarf that does
XYZ so that's got to be important you
have to play that up and it comes from
what are the frustrations of your
customers it could be something
practical like I need to stay warm you
know in current scarfs don't do that
well enough or it could be something
more in a fashion statement you know I
want to stand out I want to be a rebel I
want to be different I want people to
notice me and your scarf can help them
do that this is the value that you're
adding you have to figure out what more
you can add on top of a regular boring
scarf that everybody else is selling so
I love the social component and for
everybody who's watching who's thinking
about giving back it's your duty as an
entrepreneur to give back in some way
doesn't have to be a lot it doesn't be a
lot of money it could be your time but
it's your duty to give back you do it to
do it not because it helps your sales
you do it because it's the right thing
to do and it's okay to use that in your
marketing but on top of that you have to
have something different creative unique
that adds value to the lives of your
customers in a way that your competition
does not do when you figure that out you
are on the fast track to success with
your business
belief if you guys like this video
thumbs up below it always makes me want
to do more for you and please leave a
comment below even if you just want to
say I'm watching thanks for making the
video
I love seeing those come in they really
make my day all day when I see them come
in so thank you so much and I'll see you
soon